avec tout ce que j'entends puis ce qui
se passe ailleurs qu'est ce qui ne
garantit que la qualité de l'air est là
dans montréalaise à gauthier demeure à
quelques pas de là finir ici cr l'une
des 89 entreprises au québec qui a le
droit de contrevenir à des normes
environnementales sur les rejets dans
l'air et l'eau à la suite d'ententes
signées avec le gouvernement du québec
n'est pas peu fier des mines et des
alumineries certains d'entrés elles sont
situées d'un des milieux urbains quels
sont les grands absents et ni quelles
sont les normes qui ont été fixés c'est
avocate spécialisée en environnement se
désole qu'il soit actuellement
impossible de répondre à ces questions
ces informations notamment sur tout ce
qui est les contaminants dans
l'environnement
c'est quand même assez voir que ma
façon
à québec l'opposition déplore que la loi
sur la qualité de l'environnement ne
remplit pas correctement sa mission non
je trouve pas ça normal puis je pense
surtout qu'il ya une loi qui a été passé
en 2017 qui demandaient plus de
transparence si une leçon qu'on peut
retenir de ce qui s'est passé à rouyn
noranda c'est vraiment qu'on ne peut pas
confère confiance à ces multinationales
pollueuses qui fondent le biais attendu
de pied ferme le ministre de
l'environnement s'est engagé mercredi à
dévoiler au cours des prochains jours
les détails des ententes te dire qu'elle
ait l'autorisation la nature de
l'autorisation qui est donné mais
également le degré de contamination
excédentaire dans la liste des
entreprises deux sont situés à montréal
et 7 dans la capitale nationale c'est
toutefois dans les régions du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean et du nord du
québec que l'on entend que le plus soit
onze entreprises dans chacune d'elles
interrogé sur ces nouvelles révélations
le directeur national de la santé
publique se fait tout de même rassurant
lorsqu'il ya des expositions des
populations
nous sommes normalement invités à
regarder quelques années et surtout s'il
ya des départs les directions de santé
publique de toutes les régions sont
mobilisés aussi là dessus et
régulièrement il
que ce soit dans différentes régions et
même québec montréal sur le soient
régulières la fonderie horne c'est une
exception soit on a pas d'écart
équivalent dans ses 89 autres dossiers
la rouerie vous tout faire quand je
pense qu'il faut pour généraliser le
citron et maintenant je n'ai aucun de
couches minces pour jacky chapeau ou en
ukraine afrique gauthier demeure
sceptique malgré tout le gouvernement
il met pas ses culottes puis la loi est
passée va à mon point de vue à moi lui
ministre de l'environnement s'est engagé
à tenir des consultations publiques
dorénavant lorsque des attestations
d'assainissement arriveront à échéance
ici à dia c'est une radio canada bon
rien